este problema dice determina el volumen
de una esfera de diámetro 14 centímetros
déjame dibujar la esfera eso parece un
círculo pero con un poco de sombra ya va
a parecer esfera ok
ahí está entonces queremos determinar el
volumen y lo que nos dan es el diámetro
el diámetro es la distancia entre los
puntos más alejados de una esfera o sea
por ejemplo este y este de acá entonces
nos dicen que esto esto es 14
centímetros 14 centímetros y nosotros
queremos determinar el volumen lo que
vamos a hacer es utilizar la fórmula de
volumen para una esfera que tal vez
después probemos o tu progresión una con
una clase de cálculo pero bueno esta
fórmula dice que el volumen es igual a
cuatro tercios x p x radio elevado al
cubo ok
aquí tenemos que el diámetro de las
ferias 14 centímetros afortunadamente en
las esferas como en los círculos el
radio es justo la mitad entonces para
determinar el radio hay que partir esto
es este 14 entre 2 hay que dividirlo
entre 2 así que nos queda aquí
siete centímetros y por lo tanto el
radio de siete centímetros
de hecho la esfera es el conjunto de
puntos que están a siete centímetros del
centro pero bueno sigamos con el
problema entonces debemos sustituir la r
aquí vamos a ver qué nos queda nos queda
que el volumen es igual a cuatro tercios
x pi x 7 centímetros 7 centímetros
al cubo al cubo ok vamos a meter esto a
la calculadora digo podríamos
aproximarlo pero pues este sería un poco
la tos o podemos tomarlo como 3.14 pero
luego hay que elevar 7 al cubo así que
para sacarnos de problemas vamos a meter
es para la calculadora de jal enciendo
entonces tenemos que hacer cuatro
tercios 4 entre 3 lo puse entre
paréntesis por pi second pi
7 elevado al cubo 7 elevado al cubo ahí
no puse paréntesis porque exponencial va
antes que multiplicar enter entonces no
dice cuánto lo tenemos que redondear
pero le voy a poner a esta decimos
entonces que sea 1400 36.8 vale entonces
esto es aproximadamente igual a 1400
36.8 centímetros cúbicos y listo
entonces tenemos que el volumen de esta
esfera es 1400 36.8 centímetros cúbicos
y con esto terminamos